[Music]
now
[Music]
uh what's the stripper powerpoint i got
to see this in your eyes now okay all
right here we go are you guys ready for
this yes okay
now
before you start worrying or getting
excited
this secret pertains to my life doesn't
affect anyone the only reason i'm
sharing
i want the people i love and trust the
most to know what's going on in my life
and just be a part of my journey okay
are you getting a dog what's going on
okay puppy what this secret does mean
i'm talented i'm cool and powerful okay
what the secret does not mean art school
i'm pregnant or endangered not pregnant
that's good
are you ready for this did you get an
acting gig
[Music]
i'm a stripper
and i love it now there are some
frequently asked questions
on my slide
so first you might be thinking why what
what's the point well it's a sex
positive environment and i can express
myself safely it's a performance the
dad's like tricks if you will i don't
know if this is the best method is that
why i've been able no i think instead
you got to just do it and then take all
the money you make and buy them like a
car or something yeah i just love the
are you really
she's i'm a stripper
he's like are you really and she just
went to the next slide
wasn't even my dad's like which
which club because i'm gonna make sure
not to go
yeah no i think she should have just
been like uh
y'all want to go to a show on saturday
and took them all there and then just
came out on stage oh god why it's sex
positive she said
and an enemy
she could have performed got off stage
sat back down with them and said what i
miss and they're like there's this great
dancer on stage and she's like oh that
was me and they're like how were they
how are they not gonna tell that it's
their own daughter
she said it's anonymous
how is it anonymous well i think her do
you think her dad knows what her [ __ ]
[ __ ] looks like they can see her face
she's not wearing a mask do they wear
masks and strip clothes i thought that's
what she was implying with the anatomy
can you say in an enemy anonymity
anonymity and an amenity her dancing up
there and then the dad's like whoa
kind of looks like yours i'm sorry i'm
sorry babe i'm sorry i'm just kidding
just kidding i like the idea of the dad
being like which club are you working at
and she's like i'm sapphire just like
[ __ ]
love that place god damn it
great what nights of the week
saturdays i'm guessing cool the best
night [ __ ]
tuesday as well oh well [ __ ] me
[ __ ] i can't have anything nice can i
you know that i started this family to
do something great and just bit by bit
you all take from me you
take my favorite things first her you
took my whole [ __ ] life away because
you're the one who wanted three kids and
look at the third one now she's a
stripper and she took away my strip club
i can't go to poker night cause i gotta
take jamie to dance class
and now i can't even enjoy the
all-you-can-eat wings buffet at sapphire
on a tuesday whole family just like
and the daughter's like
i'ma just close the laptop i'm sorry i
didn't mean to trigger you i'm sorry
it's just not even about her being a
stripper anymore
dad's like
what's for dinner anyways wife's like
i thought maybe we'd have domino god
[ __ ] damn it oh we could go get the
wings if that would make you feel better
i don't want the [ __ ] wings with you
i want to go with the boys who i rarely
see anymore you know what this is gonna
do to me you know what's gonna do to me
now every time the boys go to sapphire
they're gonna be looking at you making
fun of me we're getting a little carried
away we're getting a little carried away
it's getting a bit theatric
we got some theatrics this episode see
what happens when we get on the ship
after 12. yeah it's way more it's a
different vibe that's way more fun i
agree we we've learned this lesson many
times and we keep [ __ ] it up
don't what is this don't why have you
had this on the screen don't
don't don't what don't even begin to
make fun of this these are real life
nfts
no this is just an example of what
stripping and anonymous would look like
oh
yeah that's hot yeah that's [ __ ] hot
we should make a
tv show called the masked stripper yeah
with with that owl [ __ ]
that is absolutely what i want to see oh
yeah i would watch that giraffe
bust it wide open
all right man you can quote me on that
please clip that please clip that
presentation for strip club is kind of
like interesting
yeah it's a good i guess it's a good way
to um ease them into the idea would be
funny if she played a series of
strippers
to be like okay now if i were to just
play this clip tell me what you feel
she just starts going through more
the dad's like um
this is pretty good she's like an eight
no i didn't ask you to
oh
what you guys think of that [ __ ] hot
honey this is me right after this show
i'm going right to the gym doing leg day
baby
happy leg day
[Laughter]
what do i do
why is it
wait
[Laughter]
i was crying
this [ __ ] logic project
[Laughter]
unexpected item in [ __ ]
[Laughter]
bro i hope we just break everybody so
if anyone whether you're a lady or
a a dude
if someone nuts too quick i hope this is
what you guys think of play it one more
time burn it in their brain
[ __ ]
just like a lady laid up on her back
dude not seen her she goes
unexpected item and [ __ ] he's like what
you just give me that towel
what'd you just say to me
unexpected item in [ __ ] it's a tick
tock
i don't know that one go to this go to
the fat uh f fact oh the fake vaccine
card again
24 year old chloe merzak from illinois
was arrested after allegedly using this
fake covet 19 vaccine card to enter
hawaii and avoid travel restrictions so
go down to like the first reply
yeah she said she got madonna mad aaron
that wasn't the only thing there was
like six different things six hundred
dollars for a flight to hawaii and also
paid for a fake vax card says she
she was vaccine delaware even though she
lives in illinois says the second dose
was five weeks after the first dose
um
and it says moderna moderna with an a i
guess this isn't that funny [ __ ] yeah
have you made your arrangements for what
to jump off a building because you just
literally [ __ ] that bit up so bad such
a small ball thing to do
my sound this thing isn't even
they're laughing
they're laughing but yeah at your small
balls i mean it's funny it's fine i'm
modderno with an a
yeah
yeah no it is good
good thing you quit your job for this
why did we do this stupid episode
i hate this
you